welcome to this video playing Grand
Master Gaston that's a real opponent
really yeah this is Grandmaster shrewder
from Chile I'm this really strong bits
player but he doesn't play the
five-minute port of him but you see if
he plays it he scores well I have lost
one game against him earlier with the
Chazz explained account at least it's
worthless what the statistics is telling
me okay I'm playing my usual chigorin
yeah I know that this is not the
greatest line ever but it's yeah it's
it's what I do it's it's a fairly solid
thing and I I normally can play this
really quickly
yeah what what he wants to do is maybe
long-term play on the G farm yeah this
is an interesting question I can also
open it up a little bit
do I want to now I can also close it
down totally it's not that big of a
problem I would love to get in the ship
to age six yeah trading and trading
stuff there but that's not easy let's
see White's main idea here is to put
something on there five like a peace
sacrifice mmm he's regrouping again
let's see yeah it's not so easy to make
progress for right of course I'm just
standing there and who would the thing I
cannot do many active things it's also
why this is a line that I really intend
to to bend from my repertoire for for a
long time but I somehow somehow keep
playing it also because my results are
not that bad even though I understand
that the physician is not looking very
attractive I am playing for yep later
later Bishop h6 but now okay this is a
different story he has played he has
played f4 which is leading to now a
totally different position
let's see him how to play that he's
actually allowing this move not sure if
I should do it but I will I will just
trade off this Bishop I can also put it
on one g5 I don't need to take
necessarily can I put put the Queen on
aged six here maybe something like that
okay this is a trade that I don't mind
really not okay my knight on c7
trying to regroup it I have accomplished
something by trading off my my
dark-squared bishop yeah that is
actually helpful for me because I only
have one night for the e5 square I think
this was a strategic concession that he
made them I know I know I'm okay really
I don't think something terrible is
going on now what I'm still not able to
do do much but wonder can I do something
I can try to put the knight on d5 maybe
but what what he's doing here I mean
maybe he cannot do very much but it
feels a little bit like okay I can't get
when g5 and just close this thing down
shortly
raaah Harvard Jeff it is a little bit
now the question is can i play for a win
here yeah no no I don't really see how I
lose rookie seven the ship to g6
I'm trying that I mean how am I ever
going to lose him probably I cannot win
but okay
yeah it's probably not leading to much
both I mean
Chiharu cage 3 strongly it's through a
very very solid fun time warning is
going to play g3 and I'm not not getting
anywhere check sure that's that's
interesting
that's not very convenient with with no
time on the clock yeah okay that was it
was the vibe wasn't very wise to play on
he's just he didn't do anything ever in
this game besides trading all the wrong
pieces and getting to his endgame but he
was quick doing it yeah black resigns
yeah I mean white is just worse here and
but I didn't find the right way forward
what exactly did I do wrong I mean here
why this really just just much worse
it'sit's always problematic if you're
down one time hmm King f6 then sort of
regroup maybe I have no way forward I
mean the comp is also giving me a pretty
decent edge but Ruby 7 and I'm winning
according to the comp what am I doing
this I have to go to g4 Andrew kept
several this is the one yeah I mean he
did one one good thing in this game the
c5 move was just strong that was very
strong other than that he was just
shuffling without any any big purpose
I'm sorry I'm just honest yeah I mean
it's nothing I'm not doing anything I'm
just analyzing this is strong yeah you
should be strong so I have to have to do
this and then I'm winning rah
yeah oh it's a little bit worried that
he might enter with the rook here but I
had his check and this is indeed very
strong
something like that it's a total
invasion yes this bishop that he
basically yeah made to be a very bad
piece here black is just winning up yeah
I was correct in declining the draw and
it was clear that only black and win but
I bought this really if I was strong to
see five new so strong he spotted this
this particular moon a moment very well
that and after that I'm really am almost
lost them because he will break through
here and the deep one will be much
stronger than my Jeep on yeah okay
thanks for watching